Our Uzbillahi mina Shaytan regime Bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim Allahumma Salli Allah Sayyidina Muhammadin Waala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin Kamasallaita wa salam tawa baraktawa rahim tawa tarahamta Allah Ibrahim Waala Ali Ibrahim Falalamina Inna Kahamidum Majid Rabbish Rahli Sadri Wa Yaserly Amri Wahlul Rukhdatam Ilissani Yaf Kahu Kawli Assalam Alaikum wa Rahmatullahi wa Barakatu
Now that we understand the linguistic meanings of the basic terms that I've explained so far in these sessions, now it's time to start with the Basmallah, which is actually the first verse of Suratul Fateha, Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
So Arabs had this way of shortening these commonly repeated statements.
So if they wanted to refer to Bismillah, Rahman or Raheem, they would instead of saying the statement completely, they would just shorten it down to Basmallah.
Right?
And so for example, La hawla wala kuwata illa billah, they just simply would call it Hauqala.
Similarly, they would use Hamdullah for Alhamdulillahi Rabbila Alameen and so on.
So
The term Basmala, it actually refers to the first verse of Suratul Fatiha which is Bismillahur Rahmanur Raheem.
Now, today what I want to focus on is this concept of being and attributes because Allah is a being, He's an entity and then He has all these various attributes and this is quite a complicated topic so you know
tried to make it as simple as possible but there are literally books written on this so it's very difficult to condense this this huge topic but if you look at the statement of Bismillahur Rahmanur Rahim from a grammatical point of view you'll see that in the context of mentioning Allah it uses a noun and it uses two adjectives
right the word Allah in Bismillah the word Allah is a noun representing an entity a being and then you have two attributes of Rahma ar-Rahman ar-Rahim right these are the adjectives or the attributes describing the nature of Allah
that he is Allah and his nature is Rahman and Raheem.
So let's talk about this distinction between Allah's name and his attributes which is essentially the distinction between the concepts of a noun and adjectives if you look at it from a grammatical point of view.
Attributes or adjectives are tools that have been provided to us by language in order for us to understand something.
In other words, it is through the combination of these two things, noun and adjectives, or name and attributes, that we actually understand an entity, right?
So if you want to gain a complete understanding of an entity, you need to understand its attributes.
In the Arabic language, this is called dhat and sifat, being and attributes.
So for instance, we have a soul and we have a body, which together constitute our zat, our being.
But then soul has certain spiritual attributes, right?
It can be kind, it can be brave, intelligent, generous, or it can be weak, it can be coward, it can be dumb, right?
In the same way, the body has its own set of physical attributes, fat, thin,
black, brown, white, tall, short.
And once we understand these spiritual and physical attributes that are describing the entity, which is the soul or the body, we essentially come to recognize the nature of that being.
So the union of the two, they provide the identity and a complete description of that identity, which then enables our intellects to understand the nature of that being.
But the thing is attributes cannot exist without the being, right?
It is the Zaat that gives existence to the Sifaat.
Attributes can only exist after the existence of the being itself.
So if there is no Allah, there cannot be a Rahman and Rahim.
So that is why the name Allah is greater in its rank than a Rahman or Rahim on the basis of its precedence.
So now if we start breaking down the statement of the Basmala, the term Allah points to His Zaat, to His being.
You know, He is a deity named Allah.
Allah is the title of His essence.
As He says in the Quran, Inna ni anallahu la ilaha illa ana.
no doubt I am Allah and there is no one worthy of worship and obedience except me now this noun Allah has adjectives which are his 99 sifat his attributes describing the nature of Allah right these are his various manifestations in his interactions with creation so now you have
Al-Rahman, Al-Raheem, Al-Malik, Al-Quddus, As-Salam, Al-Mu'min, Al-Mu'min, Al-Aziz, Al-Jabbar, Al-Mutakabbir, Al-Khalik, Al-Bari, Al-Musawwir, Al-Ghaffar, Al-Kahar, Al-Wahab, Al-Fatah, Al-Alim, Al-Kabid, Al-Basit, Al-Kafid, Al-Rafa, Al-Mu'iz, Al-Muzil, Al-Samir, Al-Basir, Al-Hakam, Al-Hakim, Al-Adil, Al-Latif, Al-Halim, Al-Kabir, Al-Azim, Al-Ghafur, Al-Al-Kabir, Al-Hafiz, Al-Hasib, Al-Karim,
Al-Muqeem, Al-Raqib, Al-Jalil, Al-Mujib, Al-Wasir, Al-Wudud, Al-Majid, Al-Ba'ith, Al-Shaheed, Al-Waqil, Al-Kawi, Al-Mateen, Al-Wali, Al-Hamid, Al-Muhsi, Al-Mubdi, Al-Mu'id, Al-Muhhi, Al-Mumi, Al-Hayy, Al-Qayyum.
Al-Wajid, Al-Majid, Al-Wahid, Al-Samad, Al-Qadil, Al-Muqtadir, Al-Muqaddim, Al-Mu'akhir, Al-Awal, Al-Akhir, Al-Zahir, Al-Batin, Al-Wali, Al-Muta'ali, Al-Bir, Al-Tawwab, Al-Muntakim, Al-Afoo, Al-Ra'oof.
Al-Malik, Al-Mulk, Dhul Jalali, Wali Karam, Al-Muqsit, Al-Jamiya, Al-Ghani, Al-Mukni, Al-Maniya, Adhdar, An-Nafir, An-Noor, Al-Hadi, Al-Badir, Al-Baqi, Al-Warif, Al-Rashid, Al-Sabur, Al-Hanan, Al-Manan, Al-Dayan, Al-Burhan So now these are all these attributes that describe the nature of Allah and to use the example of the prism and the light that I stated in one of the previous sessions
Now you can think of Allah as the term Allah as one pure light, right?
He is the light of the heavens and the earth.
Now when this pure light of the name Allah comes into the physical realm, His divine attributes refract within creation.
The light of Allah splits into these 99 attributes within His creation.
so now we get all these different manifestations of Allah's essence based on His interaction with His creation so in one instance we see that Allah is Kareem He is generous but then in another instance we see He is Jabbar the compeller in another instance we see He is Ahar the subduer in another we see that He is Al-Aziz the powerful in another we see He is Musil
the one who humbles but then he's also al-mua is the one who bestows honor so his essence manifests through all these different attributes within creation this world then becomes a theater for the divine manifestation of Allah's attributes enabling us to know who Allah is not directly through his essence but
through the refraction of His attributes and His creations.
This is why it is said, La tafakkur fi laa, walaa kin tafakkur fi khal qillah, do not reflect upon Allah, but rather reflect upon the creations of Allah.
Why?
Because it is creation, it is nature that manifests all of His attributes for us.
So if you want to understand Allah, look outside yourself and look within yourself.
We will keep showing them our signs within their own, within the horizons and within their own souls until it becomes perfectly clear to them that all of this is from Alhaq.
But then Allah is infinite.
and so are his attributes this is why when we attempt to understand Allah we get bewildered by his attributes because in a sense we cannot know what God is any more than we can know what God isn't you see because when we speak about Allah
we are speaking about this infinite creator of the heavens and the earth.
And the word infinite means without a limit.
Now the word in Arabic for definition is the same word that we use for a limitation or a boundary.
A definition is what defines or gives finiteness to something, a concept.
It limits it, it demarcates it, it puts it into perspective.
So when we talk about Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, we cannot define God.
Because to define Him would mean to give Him a hut, a boundary, right?
We would have to place Him in a limit, which is impossible, because, you know, He is without any limit.
The way the intellect works, Aqala means to create a boundary.
Right?
That's the only way human intellect works.
That's the only way we know how to grasp or understand something by creating a boundary, by creating a limit.
And Allah cannot be limited.
And this is why scholars say that all of Aqeedah, this concept of creed, it can be reduced into two statements.
He is unlike anything.
La yush bihuzatuhu al-zawaat wala muta'atila tus sifaat That His essence is not like any other essence and His attributes are not in any way metaphorical.
He is al-ghaniyu anil jameer wal jameeru muftaqarun ilaih He has no need of anyone and everyone is in need of Him.
So this statement actually negates need for Allah and it enforces need for the rest of creation.
It negates independence for us.
Now here is where we get into another central problem with religion and that is the problem of transcendence and eminence.
transcendence is when we speak about God without anything you know any reference in this world that can guide us to him there is nothing in the world for which we can say you know that is God or this is like God because Allah is above and beyond anything they ascribe to
so when we talk about transcendence we're talking about Allah being above and beyond everything that we know of right that's why we say subhanaka which is in Arabic the word it means transcendence and it comes from which means to purify to get rid of filth you know to transcend something to be above and beyond something so Allah is transcendent
But then pure transcendence has a lot of problems by itself.
Because then now Allah becomes the God of the scientist.
Like Einstein believed in a God, but he did not believe in a personal God, right?
He believed in a transcendent God.
The God he believed in was the God of the deist who has nothing to do with his creation.
And then that again creates a major problem.
But then there is also this concept of eminence, the idea of God being close to us in the world.
So for example, like in Hinduism, right, the Brahman class, they don't really believe in idols.
You know, we generally, when we think of a Hindu, we think they are idol worshipers, but this class of Brahmans, right, they don't really believe in idols.
It's really a kind of trick
to help all these stupid people of the lower class that they believe who they feel that still need to evolve.
So there's this understanding in their tradition that the lower classes or the caste system that they have, which they call the varna.
So if you're in a lesser varna, you cannot understand the Brahma.
That's what they believe because he has gone through several lifetimes to get this ability to perceive.
and It is something that only he can perceive and only he can understand the Godhead as they call it Right, so so brahma understands the God that has no attribute Which they call the nirguna but they have this idea that the lower class people actually need to see something in order to understand God and So they gave them all these idols.
It's the brahman class that gave
idols, this concept of idols to the lower classes, to the lower varna, who they actually knew were not gods.
But they thought that it helps the common people understand God.
And this is the problem of eminence in religion, which is creating likeness for God.
You understand?
the way Christianity deals with this problem is obviously through Jesus because Jesus becomes this incarnation of God right God enters into flesh and in our tradition this is what is called Hulul where God enters the flesh and some of the deviant Sufis they actually claim the state so this is not something specific to Christianity you know we know that there was a group called Nuseri that claimed divinity for Maulana Ali
And it actually also happened for Imam Jafar Sadiq and other Imams as well.
So now how do we understand this concept of eminence in our religion?
What is the relationship between transcendence and eminence?
Tanzir and Tajrid?
Because you do need an access to your master, right?
If you have a completely transcendent God, he becomes this cold, distant,
uncaring unloving God on the other hand if you give God the attributes of creation you now have a whole new problem and that's what gives birth to these concepts of anthropomorphism falling into this idea that God is petulant that God has emotions that God has anger that he has pleasure in an anthropomorphic way
and and this is something that you know penetrates the Muslim understanding as well there are Muslims who think that when these words are used in the Hadith or the Quran so for example when Allah says the one who faced the anger of Allah they think that Allah's anger is like our anger that Allah becomes angry in an emotional sense and that's not true
because Allah is above and beyond anything that is ascribed to him but we do believe that Ghadab has a meaning and we believe that Rida has a meaning you know we believe that these words that Allah used in the Quran like radiAllahu anhum wa raduan they were pleased with Allah and Allah was pleased with them but don't think your
pleasure with Allah is the same as Allah's pleasure with you don't think those two words mean the same thing in the context they are being used each means a specific thing in relation to that thing that it is predicating so when we talk about the attributes of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala we have to be extremely careful when we when we try to create an understanding of these attributes we have to be extremely careful because
we in a sense can only say about Allah what Allah has said about Himself we cannot you know Allah what any description that Allah needed for our understanding He described it Himself in the Quran but then now here we enter into another problem which is the problem of interpretation because even though Allah is telling us things about Himself in the Quran
Even though he is self-disclosing to us, he is self-disclosing through language.
And language is filtered through the human mind.
And the human mind has the capacity to interpret what is being said in so many different ways.
So now we have a whole new set of problems.
And this is why we stick to the Prophet and his Wasi.
right because they are the purest filter for us and they're still a filter right the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam is also a filter but he is the purest filter and this is why the prophets have a capacity that other human beings do not have and that is that you know Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has chosen them to be these filters for revelation
And that is why the best understanding of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is the understanding that our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam has articulated to us.
And this is what he said, Allahumma la nuhsina sana'a alaika antakama isnai ta'ala nafsik O Allah, we are unable to praise you.
You are as you praised yourself.
In other words, I cannot truly praise you.
Because one of the reasons that we praise is based on our knowledge of the praiseworthy, right?
If you don't know the qualities of someone or something, you cannot really praise it.
You cannot really praise them.
And this is why in Allah's self-disclosure to us, He is describing for us the reasons why He is praiseworthy, the reasons why He is a Hamid.
He has described to us, explained to us in the Quran the praiseworthy attributes that he has and why.
This is how understanding the attributes of Allah enables us to come to know Allah.
But these attributes are known to us through our human experience.
And that's where you get into the problem of eminence.
you know there has to be some correlation between what we understand about Allah and what we understand about ourselves or what we see in the world because otherwise we just simply cannot know Allah it just wouldn't be possible and so in dealing with the attributes of Allah you are still working with things in this world you see
So when we say Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala is for instance Qadeem, right?
And Qadeem becomes a problematic word because it's a technical word.
It is not found in the Quran.
It is not actually an attribute of Allah.
It's more of a technical word.
Qidam is what they call a salbi attribute because it negates hadith.
I know this is getting complicated, but basically it negates occurrence.
That's what
Qadeen means it negates occurrence, it negates the fact that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is hadatha, that He came into existence.
No, Allah did not come into existence.
The idea of qidam is that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is as He always was and He will always continue to be the same way without any change or any time factor.
And this is where pre-eternity becomes the best word in English that we can use.
When we say pre-eternity, I don't even know what that means.
I really don't.
But it's a word that, I mean, how can you describe pre-eternity?
You cannot even describe eternity because eternity means forever.
And so how do you use pre with eternity?
How can there be something before that is eternal, right?
So I really don't know what that word means.
I cannot.
I have a sense of what that word means, but I cannot really describe it.
But that's the word that that at best what we have come up with as a way of describing Allah's existence.
Subhanallah.
So you can see that we run into all these problems when we try to understand Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and so malana Ali alaihis salam he gave us this simple simple formula for recognition of Allah, which is ala'idzu an darakal idarakuhu idarak.
Well, bahasu anzatihi kufru wa ishraq.
My inability to recognize Allah is recognizing Allah.
My inability to recognize Allah, my inability of my intellectual powers to create a boundary, to create a definition around Allah, the meaning of Allah, the understanding of Allah is recognizing Him.
And any attempt to discuss His essence is
It will inevitably result in assigning and attributing partners with Him, creating likeness for Him.
So accepting our inability to know Allah is our true recognition of Him.
And this is why the most essential act in worship in Islam is the act of Sijda, putting our intellects on the ground and surrendering its capacity to recognize Allah.
Now, Quran gives us an incredibly concise statement to help us understand Allah.
Because the way in which we understand this world around us is through things, right?
The Arabic word for a thing is Shai, right?
The word Shai, it means thing and this word it comes from Sha'a which means
will the will of Allah everything every being every Zaat that exists in this world has its own individual set of attributes right every noun has its adjectives all of which points to what they point to the mancha to the will and the purpose of their creator so every Shai is
Azat, it's a being, it's an entity which has its own set of attributes or Sifaat.
And they are a sign, they are a means, they are a tool for us to understand the mansha of the Creator, the will and the purpose of the Creator.
But when it comes to Allah Himself, when it comes to the Creator Himself, there is no thing, there is no shai that can be compared to Him in any way, shape or form.
And so the Quran beautifully explains this concept to us through one single word in an ayah, kamithlihi.
No matter what you do, no matter how high your imaginations fly, no matter how deep your thoughts dive,
there is absolutely no way for you to understand Allah because there is no thing no being no attribute in existence whether it's physical or spiritual or metaphysical or conceptual or theoretical there is nothing that is like Allah there is absolutely nothing that you can use to compare it to Allah or to create a likeness for Allah subhanAllah
Now I want you to take a moment to really let this paradox sink in.
He created this magnificent universe all around us.
Every single entity with its attributes is reflecting His divine existence.
It's reflecting His own attributes for us.
so that we can gain a semblance of understanding of His powers, His glory, His majesty, His wrath, His love, His everything.
And then once we do manage to get some feeble understanding of His attributes in creation, He says, Laisaka mithlihishay.
Look, whatever little now that you think you know about Me, understand that I'm not like that.
I'm way beyond it.
And what's so incredible is that he does this linguistically through the use of one single word.
This is not a word that is commonly used and it was not even used in classical Arabic.
The ancient Arabs actually never used this word.
This is a word that is used in only in eloquence of the Quran.
So from a grammatical standpoint, the word is actually two words.
There is the word
and then there is the word mislihi.
These are both words that are used for comparison, but they are never fused together in this manner.
They are always used individually.
So let's try to understand the subtlety in the usage of this word camislihi.
It's really beautiful.
So in Arabic,
When you want to compare something in attributes, now you understand the difference between zat and sefat, right?
The noun and adjectives, being an attribute.
So anytime you want to create a comparison in attributes, you add the letter ka before it, okay?
So for example, if I wanna compare the bravity of Zed to a lion, right?
So if I wanna say that Zed is brave like a lion,
I will have to use the letter ka to do that.
So I'll say Zaidun kal asad.
I'm saying Zaid is like a lion.
Now what am I comparing here?
I'm comparing the attribute of bravery of a lion with Zaid.
So I'm using the letter ka.
Zaidun kal asad.
But when I need to establish a comparison in essence, I cannot use the word ka.
You understand?
Grammatically that would be wrong.
I will now have to use the word mithal.
So for example, I will say .
A cub is similar to a lion.
The son of a lion is like the lion.
Here I'm using the word mithal because I'm not comparing in attributes.
I'm actually comparing the essence of these two entities, the lion and the cub.
So this is a rule of the Arabic language that when
you know when you're establishing comparisons both words ka and misal they are used in very precise ways and we find this distinction all over Arabic poetry so for example there is this poet who is praising the generosity of a king and comparing it to an ocean right now what is generosity is it being or is it an attribute it's an attribute so he's comparing
the generosity of this king to the ocean.
So he has to use the letter ka.
So he says, kal bahari yaq de foolil kari bila aliya judan wa yaba asulil ba'idi sahaiba.
He says, the king is generous like the ocean.
When I move closer to him, he gives me pearls, and when I move away from him, he sends clouds filled with rain.
So here he uses the word ka.
because he is comparing the attributes of generosity but when the being or the entity needs to be compared the word mithal has to be used so the poet says I am a lion and this is my son indeed the son of a lion is like the lion so now because the comparison is being
done in the Zaat, in the entity itself, the poet is using the word Mithil.
So I hope this gives you a much better understanding of this subtlety, because you know that is what makes this ayah so beautiful.
Allah says To compare Himself, what Allah does in this verse is that He fuses both the Ka and the Mithil together to create this one word, Kamiflih.
Why is that?
Because we just learned that ka is used for attributes and missile is used for the entity itself.
So what Allah is saying is that whether you try to compare me to attributes of creation, ka, or if you try to compare me to the essence of creation, missile,
In both cases, you will fail, because Laisa ka mislihi shayoon.
There is nothing that exists in attributes, and there is nothing that exists in essence that you can use to compare to me.
Subhanallah.
Can you appreciate the beauty of this word?
It's incredible.
This is eloquence at its best.
I mean...
There is nothing comparable to Me in attributes.
Mithil There is nothing comparable to Me in beingness, in existence.
Ka mithlihi There is nothing comparable to Me in attributes or in being.
Laisa ka mithlihi shayun There is no thing, whether physical, metaphysical, spiritual, conceptual, theoretical, practical, there is simply no shay.
That you can use to create a comparison or a likeness for me not in attributes not in essence subhanallah So now that we understand this concept What the basmallah does is that it condenses all the attributes of Allah subhana wa ta'ala into two primary attributes ar-rahman and ar-rahim in other words the
two attributes that will always be present in each and every single interaction of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala with his creation is are the attributes of Rahma ar-Rahman and ar-Raheem intense mercy consistent mercy so when we say Bismillah ar-Rahman ar-Raheem in essence we are remembering the these the essence of Allah
Right?
Because it is Allah who is Rahman and Rahim.
So we're remembering, reminding ourselves of the essence of Allah which is manifesting for us through these two primary attributes of Rahma.
So what this does is that in a sense it implodes all of his remaining attributes.
It sucks in all of its remaining attributes into this concept of Rahma.
You see, in other words, regardless of the way in which Allah is interacting with us right now, His Rahma is present in that manifestation.
Even if He is manifesting in my life right this moment as Al-Jabbar or Al-Qahar, His Rahmaniya, His Rahimiya, His Rahma, His love, His care, His compassion, His concern, His mercy, it's always present in His interaction with me.
there is a lot more to be you know explained about this inshallah we'll move this conversation forward in the next session wahro dawan alhamdulillah here Abdul Alamin wasalatu wasalamu ala rasuli he saidana Muhammadan Khatim and Nabin was sayedal Musaleen wala akhi he wa wasi ali nabi Taliba shrafal wasiyin wa alalayima teamin zoriatima taibi natahirin wasalam alayhi majmain al Fatih